Okay, let's go.
Let's talk to, um, let's talk to our caller
from the five one three area code.
Who's calling today from five one three.
Hey David, this is [inaudible] from Cincinnati,
Ohio.
Hey.
Oh, what's going on?
Um, yeah.
So I just have two quick questions.
So the first question is, in regards to, um,
what Ronald Reagan said to Richard Nixon,
um, I don't know if you've seen this article,
but it's a bungalow.
Ronald Reagan talking to the next set about
his complaints about an delegation in the
year went on.
He called them monkeys.
Yes.
Yeah.
You said that they looked uncomfortable and
choose N. I mean, honestly like looking at
it, I'm not really surprised that he said
that, but a lot of people, including my conservative
friends are, so I just wanted to get your
thoughts on that.
I'm not hugely surprised that, you know, Nixon
has his whole host of, uh, uh, extremely antisemitic
comments that he would make even to Henry
Kissinger who is himself Jewish.
I mean, it's great.
It's crazy.
I don't find it hugely surprising.
It doesn't mean that I necessarily assumed
there was tape of Reagan calling black people
monkeys, and now it's just like, obviously
we, we've uncovered it.
It's just not hugely surprising.
And you know, Reagan's entire, in a less cartoonish
way.
Reagan's his tire story, uh, an imagery around
like the welfare queen with the Cadillac or
whatever, the details kind of escaped me.
Now it's extremely racially tinge and, and
sort of contains dog whistles.
So now none of it's really surprising to me.
Yeah.
I just find it interesting because the Republican
themselves on being the party of Reagan and
party of Trump in it turns out that, you know,
both of those people are pretty racist.
But I'm just going onto my second question.
I was watching your, um, so yesterday about
how to lose against Trump.
And the first one was really interesting to
me on, you know, how, you know, letting Trump
set the narrative is a way to help them win.
So I guess my question is, uh, what can we
do to like not allow Donald Trump to set the
narrative?
Because I know that every time he says something
now blatantly racist, you know, we, and the
news media, you know, to cover up for days
upon days upon days and it just seems like
a big distraction to me.
It's just in the, it's not that we ignore.
So, so like an example would be with the Baltimore
racist stuff, the debate shouldn't be for
five days about is it or isn't it racist?
And is he definitely referring to black people
when he uses infestation type language or
only may be like, that allows him to set the
narrative.
We can talk about this is a president who
uses Twitter as a propaganda tool.
Here are all the things that he is doing while
this debate rages and are the things that
are extraordinarily damaging to Americans.
Trump's personal view about whether Baltimore
is or isn't infested is much less relevant
than what he's actually doing at the border
and then what he's doing on trade, et cetera.
So we don't pretend like Twitter doesn't exist,
but we should cover it in a way where we critique
it as a propaganda tool that Donald Trump
is using rather than just have debates about
how racist where the comments, if that makes
sense.
Yeah, it does.
Um, and yeah, thank you for taking my call,
man.
All right.
Oh, great to hear from you.
Great to hear.
Uh, from people all over the country.
Okay, great.
We will talk to you again very soon.